codify like children's right to their
mother and father once you do that you
immediately know what marriage is
supposed to be it is not a vehicle for
adult fulfillment it is a matter of
justice for children it is the primary
way that we solve all of the social
issues that we're facing today from
homelessness to child poverty to teen
suicide and high school dropout and teen
pregnancy and high incarceration rates I
mean like you cannot look at a social
issue today without drilling down and
seeing that all of those demographics
have something in common and that is
they are overpopulated with fatherless
kids